alors que le procès du couple balkany a
repris cette semaine à paris en appel
cette fois ci c'est sans la présence de
patrick balkany qui se trouverait dans
un état de santé préoccupant et ce mardi
pour le deuxième jour des audiences
c'est isabelle qui à son tour ne s'est
pas présenté au tribunal se trouvant
selon ses mots épuisé physiquement et
psychologiquement si le couple avait été
condamné en première instance à quatre
et cinq ans de prison pour blanchiment
et prise illégale d'intérêt pour avoir
dissimulé 13 millions d'euros au fisc il
avait décidé de faire appel de cette
décision qui aujourd'hui est une
nouvelle fois jugé mais lors de cette
première condamnation contrairement à
son mari isabelle balkany ne s'étaient
pas vus imposer un mandat de dépôt lui
permettant ainsi de rester à son
domicile plutôt qu'en prison aujourd'hui
c'est la santé de patrick balkany 71 ans
qui interrogent depuis plusieurs mois
ses avocats enchaîne sans succès les
demandes de libération de leur client en
raison des différents problèmes de santé
auxquels ils seraient confrontés et pour
lesquelles il aurait été à plusieurs
reprises hospitalisé l'ancien maire de
levallois s'était exprimée il ya
plusieurs semaines sur son état j'ai été
opéré d'une tumeur à la colonne
vertébrale
on m'a enlevé la moitié d'une vertèbre
j'ai une plaque et civis je suis en
prison depuis trois mois je ne peux pas
m'asseoir sur la chaise de la cellule je
suis obligée de rester allongée toute la
journée si la justice n'a pour le moment
jamais répondu favorablement à ces
requêtes de remise en liberté
qu'en pensez vous faut-il libéré patrick
balkany laurence bourdes et mathis merci
d'être avec nous vous êtes maire adjoint
aux sports à la mairie de levallois et
vous venez lancé un cri d'alarmé je
crois ce soir vous nous avez appelé au
non on a eu voilà vous avez la rédaction
vous avez dit j'ai eu patrick balkany au
téléphone et vous êtes extrêmement ok je
crois qu'il est en danger
vraiment alors d'abord il faut préciser
que ils n'appellent pas qu'il veut à la
santé il a trois numéros de téléphone
auquel il a accès notamment celui de son
épouse et elle est malheureusement elle
aussi assez fragile et ce sont des amis
donc je la côtoie beaucoup et j'essaye
de l'entrevue beaucoup de week end j'ai
eu deux dimanches où j'étais avec elle
et où patrick a appelé le premier
dimanche avant la remise en libérant la
demande de remise en liberté j'ai trouvé
déjà qu'il était assez temps pour la
petite histoire je vais je regarde la
grande rigolade
la grosse tête et j'avais retenu des
blagues j'ai voulu en parler
souvent c'est changer
duch on le voit bouder et est donc je
pensais je les ai sentis vraiment à bien
isabelle ensuite m'a expliqué que il
mettait beaucoup d'espoir dans cette
demande de remise en liberté
et elles craignent sa réaction en cas de
refus refus il ya eu
vous avez dit au téléphone il m'a dit
qu'il était en train de mourir
physiquement et intellectuellement il
n'a plus de volonté ils étaient très
hautes et sur les décisions de justice
il a baissé les bras
valérie vous pensez qu'on doit et on
doit le libérer patrick balkany
bah c'est un justiciable comme les
autres donc effectivement je pense qu'il
n'est pas le seul qui est en prison dans
des conditions peut-être difficile et
qui mériterait peut-être parce qu'il n'a
pas commis de crime de sang de qu'on
prenne en compte son état de santé
mais en même temps on peut aussi
entendre que on dirai pourquoi lui et
pas un autre
voyez donc on est dans une situation un
peu gens là qu'il entend bien il entend
bien ce discours est d'ailleurs je vais
pas polémiquer
juste le dernier bilan de santé
il fait 75 kg il a perdu 30 kilos
je me suis castaldi en face de vous en
face de moi était plus que vous puisque
vous n'offrez nos gsm il a pris 25 kg et
j'essaye d'en rire mais c'est très
inquiétant
voilà pour le poids d'un homme 75 kg ça
devient j'étais fou de soi dépend pour 1
m combien il était peut-être trop gros
peut-être que 75 si vous connaissez le
personnel il est très très grand
quelqu'un de très très gros mais et puis
les banques plus que ça je vais vous
dire une chose c'est savez le ton de la
voix
il ya des fois enfin je travaille avec
le quotidien ça fait sept ans que je le
côtoie donc on est on est allé défendre
des points de droit sur les plateaux
aujourd'hui c'est pas là du tout mon
point de vue c'est ça c'est simplement
que je ne voudrais pas avoir à regretter
de ne pas avoir alerté
donc voilà la raison on a pensé voilà
qu'est ce qu'ils souffrent énormément
physiquement aujourd'hui je pense qu'il
est en danger de mort vraiment en danger
de mort non je le crois en tout cas je
le crains vraiment ça serait tragique
ainsi si enfin je vais vous dire quelque
chose moi je pense comme moi j'aime le
personnage parce que c'est un personnage
malheureusement avec des défauts qu'on
pour une chronique enfin on a chacun nos
savoirs faudrait faire des prisons plus
grande mais le plus sérieusement on
s'attache à lui le problème c'est qu'il
est allé en prison dans un moment de sa
vie où déjà physiquement pour un
prisonnier lambda c'est dur la prison
pardon de vous dire ça je me permets de
vous le dire mais patrick balkany est
quand même dans des conditions optimales
en prison par rapport à des prisonniers
qui s'enfermer avec des rats dans des
conditions insalubres mais moi je peux
comprendre que s'il a maintenant il
meurt en prison
faudra pas oublier quand même que ce
serait une tragédie ne serait ce que
pour lui et sa famille ont la france et
l'algérie pour la france on laisse pas
mourir des gens en prison il ya des
médecins au froid il ya des médecins en
prison on peut pas penser que parce que
c'est balkany dont s'est pas non plus il
ya des médecins si ça va pas sans sa
situation on va pas laisser mourir
patrick balkany dans sa prison qui ont
loupé un talonnage que sont même titre
qu'un autre détenu sur les mairies a
marqué liberté égalité fraternité
la marque c'est pas pareil pour tout le
monde c'est quoi votre homme moi je vous
dis je pensais que c'était une blague -
caen quand on m'a dit 'il va venir ici
parce qu'il faut laisser soeur alors on
fait quoi on le fait sortir et on invite
dans tous les restaurants couscous d'île
de france pour qu'ils reprennent du
poids c'est quoi la solution c'est quoi
ce fonds qui sera géré nous je pense
qu'il ya des traitements quand même je
pense que déjà il a le droit de se faire
soigner correctement je pense qu'il est
régulièrement sorti de l'hôpital dans
des fourgons pas forcément dans des
zombies lança à des rythmes effrénés
adenauer daniel très très tôt voilà là
aussi entendons-nous je ne vais pas m je
veux dire une chose pour n'importe quel
autre détenu que je connaîtrai je
tiendrai le même discours d'accord
balkany patrick balkany le respect de la
vie humaine et pour moi importante et
qu'elle conçoit patrick bey lequel il a
aujourd'hui aujourd'hui vous êtes
inquiète pour sa santé vous avez peur
qu'il arrive un drame et vous vouliez le
dire sur ce plateau
voilà le message est passé après chacun
se fera son idée bien entendu en tout
cas merci d'avoir été avec nous laurence
bourdes et mathis